[Musik]
die wunderschönen inseln der ägäis sind
für urlauber ein paradies auf erden
mykonos santorin rhodos oder eine der
anderen mehr als 1000 griechischen insel
sicher wirst du mir zustimmen dass die
der traum eines jeden touristen sind für
eine person sind sie jedoch der blanke
albtraum von denen die rede ist
natürlich recep tayyip erdogan
denn als diese griechischen inseln
stehen in allmacht plänen des türkischen
präsidenten gehörig im weg und in athen
ist man sich dessen absolut bewusst auch
dort hat man gesehen was in der
saudischen botschaft mit jamal cascioli
gute tecan tour mit liam neeson passiert
ist und daher weiß man
istanbul ist ein ziemlich heißes
pflaster und mit ankara ist auch nicht
zu spaßen genau aus diesem grund werden
wir in diesem video zeigen wie
griechenland sich auf eine bedrohung
vorbereitet die im grunde jeder zeit
realität werden kann
genau dann nämlich wenn erdogan meint er
hätte gerade die besseren karten in der
hand bist du bereit dann legen wir los
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vor nicht allzu langer zeit waren
griechenland und die türkei wegen eines
erdbebens in den nachrichten
die zusammenstöße zwischen ankara und
athen spielen sich aber schon lange
nicht mehr nur auf der ebene
tektonischer platten ab der letzte
bedeutende konflikt ist beispielsweise
auf die ereignisse im westlichen
mittelmeer zurückzuführen genau dort
nämlich wo unter dem meeresgrund erdgas
gefunden wurde denn präsident erdogan es
nicht bereit auch nur auf einen einzigen
kubikmeter dieses rohstoffs zu
verzichten und das obwohl die frage ob
die türkei wirklich das recht hat die
gefundenen vorkommen auszubeuten ganz
und gar nicht geklärt ist denn die
vielen griechischen insel stehen ihr im
weg mit anderen worten nach
internationalen seerechts scheint ankara
nicht gerade in einer günstigen position
zu sagen die europäische union selbst
hat diese grenzen ihrer mitglieder auf
subtile weise verteidigt etwas was
ändern natürlich nicht zu akzeptieren
bereit ist hoch und es aufgrund einer
insel von zehn quadratkilometern auf
unsere küsten zu beschränken ist der
deutlichste ausdruck von unrecht und
ungerechtigkeit die bemühungen sich die
reichtümer des mittelmeers anzueignen
auf die idee anrainerstaat erreicht
hatte ist ein beispiel des modernen
kolonialismus der südsee insel auf die
sich erfahren bezieht ist kastelorizo
sie ist die östlichste bewohnten
griechische insel um die eine
vorstellung zu geben
sie liegt mehr als 500 kilometer vom
griechischen festland entfernt aber
kommt zwei kilometer von der türkischen
küste und auch wenn sich erdogan konkret
auf diese insel sieht könnte er das
gleiche auch praktisch über jede andere
griechische insel st denn in der ägäis
gehören von denen mehr als 100 bewohnten
inseln nur zwei zur türkei wir sprechen
von inseln die wenn man den wortlaut des
internationalen seerechts folgt
griechenland das recht zu leben scheinen
die ressourcen unter dem meeresgrund
auszubeuten und ihre türkischen nachbarn
außen vor zu lassen
ja wir unseren frauen erdogan aber gut
kennen müssen wir natürlich dass er
gesetze die für ihn eher unvorteilhaft
sind nicht so einfach akzeptiert nicht
war nun in der telekom an genau den
gleichen eindruck
daher bereite man sich dort aufs
schlimmste vor die direkte konfrontation
denn auch wenn uns das wie ein
schlechter film oder zumindest höchst
unwahrscheinlich erscheinen markt ist
griechenland fest entschlossen alles zu
tun um das zu verteidigen was ist nach
geltendem recht als sein eigentum
betrachtet wir wissen aber auch
entschlossenheit allein erreicht im
ernstfall ganz und gar nicht der die
türkische armee ist eine der größten der
welt und was wissen wir über die
griechische armee nun im grunde dass ich
seit könig leonidas nicht viel geändert
hat wie wir das meinen nun dass du
gleich sehen
erinnerst du dich noch daran wie donald
trump forderte alle mitglieder der nato
müssten ihren bafa wieder auf mindestens
zwei prozent ihres bip anregen nur zehn
der 30 länder des atlantischen
bündnisses erfüllen diese vorgabe
griechenland jedoch erreicht in dieser
rangliste einen überraschenden zweiten
platz knapp hinter den vereinigten
staaten
scheinbar ist athen also der
musterschüler nato eine besonderheit
hier war ist jedoch dass griechenland
auch jenes land ist das proportional
gesehen
den größten teil seiner militärausgaben
für personalaufwand aber es gibt ja die
nachfahren von der juni das bei unter
300 werden zu höheren dienst scheinbar
und entlohnt und ein weiteres merkmal
des griechischen militärbudgets des
hochgradig interessant alle
rüstungsausgaben mit denen sich treten
dann gegenüber dem rest der nato
abgeschickt werden für einen ganz
bestimmten zweck verwendet nämlich die
verteidigung gegen die türkei jetzt
zufällig auch ein nato land ist klingt
rückt und ist es auch warum nur
herrschen zwischen griechen und türken
überhaupt so viele ressentiments ist
griechenland überhaupt fit genug sich
gegen die türkei zu verteidigen und
vielleicht die wichtigste frage von
allen könnte die immer wieder straucheln
der griechischen wirtschaft den druck
eines möglichen konflikt überhaupt
standhalten heute werden sie all diese
fragen beantworten aber wie immer
dachten wir zunächst einen blick zurück
in die geschichte
der vertrag von lausanne
es gibt viele dinge die griechenland und
die türkei trennen dass abgesehen von
der ägäis
es hat es sich nicht einfach nur um eine
grenze zwischen zwei ländern
nein es ist eine grenze die zwei
kontinente zwei religionen zwei
zivilisationen trend ost und west eine
grenze die durch jahrhunderte der
konfrontation entstanden ist eine grenze
die eigentlich seit dem trojanischen
krieg eine brennpunkt ist von alexander
dem großen über wird als konstantinopel
bis zu den osmanischen türken
tatsächlich sind die aktuellen probleme
zwischen athen und ankara auf probleme
zurückzuführen die mindestens ein
jahrhundert zurück reichen nämlich bis
zum ersten weltkrieg dieser gingst du
das osmanische reich als ein völliges
desaster im feld besiegt war das so kann
bereits den vertrag von uns der preis zu
akzeptieren ein vertrag mit schwer
verdaulichen zugeständnissen wie zum
beispiel der besetzung eines teil der
anatomischen halbinsel durch
griechenland aus diesem grund griffen
türkische nationalisten und mustafa
kemal atatürk angeführt zu den waffen
und vertrieben sowie griechen als auch
den sultan die neue türkische republik
hatte daraufhin ein neues abkommen aus
dem vertrag von lausanne ein vertrag der
den verzicht griechenlands auf
australien
es war gegen inseln vor der tabelle
straße und seine gebiete in kleinasien
also anatolien vorsah im gegenzug
verzichtete die türkei darauf ansprüche
auf zypern und möglich insel in der
ägäis zu erheben zb auch die demo kahles
insel und tatsache ist dass der vertrag
wohl nur sagen heute fast 100 jahre nach
seiner unterzeichnung die hauptursache
für die spannungen zwischen griechenland
und der türkei ist
[Musik]
denn es gibt drei dinge die das
vereinbarte gleichgewicht gestört habe
zunächst wurden die dekane inseln die
italien vor der unterzeichnung des
vertrags zusammengehört nach der
niederlage in italien seinen zweiten
weltkrieg griechenland übertragen
zweitens gibt es einfach kleine insel
und die im vertrag von lausanne und zwar
nicht ausdrücklich erwähnt wurden
grafisch jedoch eindeutig zu um die
lokales artikel gehören man geht also
davon aus dass sie rechtmäßig konkurrent
richtig sind dennoch sind die türken je
einem schlupfloch und erheben ansprechen
auch wenn sie ihn vorher gar nicht
gehörten sondern eben italien und
schließlich legte der vertrag die
griechischen hoheitsgewässer um die
inseln des ethischen wert auf eine
damals standardmäßige drei meilen zone
fest also etwa 4,8 kilometer später
erweiterte griechenland diese zone doch
auch sechsmal das heißt 96 km und die
türkei erhoben weil es keinerlei
ansprüche aber was damals niemand wissen
konnte war dass bis zum ende des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts das allgemein
akzeptierte internationale seerecht die
hoheitsgewässer auf eine zwölf meilen
zone ganz im 19,3 kilometer ausdehnen
würde jetzt aber mal langsam
denn zu diesem zeitpunkt befanden sich
beide länder bereits in einer direkten
militärischen konfrontation
das lacht welt war die insel zypern ein
unabhängiges land in dem die griechisch
zypriotische mehrheit herrschte auf dem
ist jedoch eine ganz und gar nicht
unbedeutende türkische minderheit gab
zwischen diesen beiden
bevölkerungsgruppen kam es immer wieder
zu ausschreitungen
da pogromen 1963 erlebte der insel ein
blutiges weihnachten griechische
polizeikräfte verübten ein massaker
angst über türkisches willis in den
darauf folgenden unruhen kamen insgesamt
1000 super türken und mindestens 200
zyperngriechen ums leben über 100.000
zyperntürken und 165.000 zyperngriechen
flüchteten von der insel
denn die zustände waren unglaublich
barbarisch geworden der aktivist nikos
samstag brüstete sich zum beispiel damit
eigenhändig 200 türkischen frauen und
kinder ermordet zu haben als die in
athen regierende griechische militär
unter denen schlecht dass samstag dann
sogar per push als neuen präsidenten
zyperns einsetzen wollte wurde es der
regierung in ankara zur und unter der
berufung auf die integrationswerkstatt
schutzmacht landeten türkische truppen
im rahmen der operation hat im norden
der insel
obwohl die griechische militär unter
aufgrund eines drohenden krieges mit der
türkei stürzte und auch samstag sein amt
niederlegen musste einschließlich der
türkei da so die invasion über ihr
mandat als garantiemacht hinaus
auszuweiten
sie besetzte dauerhaft das nördliche
drittel der insel und gründete die
türkische republik nordzypern die bis
heute international nicht anerkannte ist
der ungelöste konflikt seitdem immer
wieder für zündstoff zwischen athen und
ankara aber zurück in die igs dort kam
es im jahr 1996 zum schwersten
zusammenstoß zwischen griechen und
türken auf der unbewohnten inseln emea
in der nähe des vatikans ab die pace und
liebe freunde die zusammenhänge die
diesen konflikt ausgelöst haben sind
ziemlich komplex
an weihnachten muss 195 nicht ein
türkisches schiff vor der insel emea
aufgrund hilfe von griechischer seite
dennis sagte es befinde sich auf
türkischem gebiet wochen später kam
deswegen ein griechischer politiker auf
das eiland und richtete dort eine
türkische flagge aus rache gingen einige
journalisten der türkischen zeitung
hürriyet auf die insel und ersetzten die
flanke durch die türkische schließlich
schickte athen griechische soldaten
sie schnitten ihr lager auf der insel
absetzen die türkische fahne wieder
durch die griechische
die griechische bonität press1 brachte
die hälfte der türkischen marine auf den
kriegsjahren die griechen würden bald
darauf bei den streithähnen standen kurz
vor der kriegserklärung aber die
vereinigten staaten griffen ein um die
ruhe wiederherzustellen und an diesem
punkt hakt du dich vielleicht die weiter
in griechenland und die türkei
heute gehen würden wenn es jetzt um
wertvolle gasvorkommen geht wenn sie
damals schon bereit waren wegen ein paar
felsen in den krieg zu ziehen nun
springende punkt ist dass die türkei
eines der nur etwa 20 länder ist die dem
internationalen seerechtsübereinkommen
nicht beigetreten sind wir sprechen über
den in montego bay unterzeichneten
vertrag der seit 1994 das internationale
seerecht geregelt eigentlich hätte die
türkei nichts gegen dieses abkommen der
einzige grund für die ablehnung ist
genau jene artikel der bisher aktas
inseln ebenso wie das festland einen
eigenen festlandsockel haben das ist
sehr wichtig für die ausbeutung von
ressourcen da ankara behauptet die
griechischen inseln vor der türkischen
küste würden über keinen eigenen chefs
verfügen nach diesen standpunkt würde
also die zone des griechischen
einflusses in lg ist auf dem festland
beginn und die zone des türkischen
einflusses auf den mehr wäre nicht durch
die griechischen inseln begrüßt das
erdgas würde dem türken gehören das
problem ist aber die türken westen gern
mit zweierlei maß dort wo es ihnen passt
akzeptieren sie die regeln von montego
bay durchaus dass die zum teil in der
türkei besitzt der insel zypern ein fest
ganz offen hat erkennen sich zum
beispiel voran
ebenso die zwölf meilen zone im voerder
eigenen hoheitsgewässer beziehungsweise
eigentlich alle länder außer natürlich
griechenland die problematik dieser
zwölf-meilen-zone schnucki nach 2020
erneut in den schlagzeilen auf unter
anderem fall griechenland im august
beschlossen hat seine hoheitsgewässer im
ionischen meer dass mit italien teilt
auf zwölf meilen zu erweitern und athen
zögerte nicht damit zu versichern dass
dies bald auch in der ägäis geschehen
wird niemand darüber
dass die türkische reaktion nicht lange
auf sich warten ließ die türkei
bezeichnet die entscheidung griechenland
seine hoheitsgewässer in der ägäis zu
erweitern als kriegsgrund hürriyet daily
news
so weit ist es bisher nicht gekommen
aber die situation ist komplizierter als
es auf den ersten blick scheint denn die
mitte rechts partei nea demokratia hatte
mitte 2009 10 in griechenland die macht
wieder erlangt so einem großen teil
gelang ihr dies durch eine
nationalistische agenda mit der sie
gegen die rechtsextreme partei
der goldene morgenröte um wählerstimmen
operiert bei den parlamentswahlen gegen
diese strategie auf aber der neue
premier ist der kuss mit zug artist ist
jetzt eine geisel des nationalistischen
flügels der nea demokratia
dieser verfügt über genügend abgeordnete
um seine regierung zu stürzen und auf
der anderen seite forderte der türkische
präsident erdogan
er werde nie zulassen dass die igs zu
einem griechischen mehr würde er ist der
ansicht die türkische staat wäre
irgendwie in ihrer möglichkeit bedroht
wenn griechenland seine hoheitsgewässer
auf zwölfmal ausdehnen würde aber am
besten du bildest dir dein eigenes
urteil anhand dieser sehen kannst wie
sich die politischen grenzen in der eg
ist kennen würden die frage lautet nun
wie um alles in der welt können diese
verzwickte konflikt gelöst werden nun
der dialog ist kompliziert weil keine
notwendigkeit sieht irgendwas
auszuhandeln die gegenwärtige situation
kommt den griechischen nationalisten
super gelegen sie haben das ziel durch
gespräche mit der türkei oder gar
zugeständnisse nur ihre popularität zu
gefährden ohne aussicht dabei etwas zu
gewinnen
[Musik]
die regierung mit so karte sitzt
zwischen den stühlen und ihre
herausforderung besteht darin sich nicht
von den nationalisten dazu hinreißen zu
lassen auf die türkischen provokationen
zu reagieren und mit mal habe ich gerade
provokationen gesagt welche provokation
nun zum beispiel ist es üblich das
türkische militär flugzeuge in den
griechischen luftraum eindringen gut da
könnte man noch sagen die weisen ja
nato-partner warum sollte man das zu eng
sehen aber das ist nicht alles vor
kurzem schickte die türkei ein
explorations schiff in die nähe von
paris um dort nach öl und gas zu suchen
wir sprechen von einem gebiet dass
griechenland reise eine ausschließliche
wirtschaftszone betrachtet und das
explorations schiff war nicht alleine
nein es wurde von einer fregatte der
türkischen marine eskortiert kommt kam
es zum zusammenstoß mit einer
griechischen fregatte
sowas ist der perfekte zündstoff um
einen konflikt zur eskalation zu treiben
wir alle wissen dass die türkei auch in
der jüngsten vergangenheit den irak und
syrien keinerlei ist kundin hatte
einseitig die initiative zu ergreifen
auf fremdes territorium vorzudringen und
dieses dauerhaft zu besetzen eine aktie
bestimmen die terrasse nach einer insel
in der geste für sie ein klassespiel
alles was fehlt ist ein geeigneter
vorwand und angesichts eines solchen
szenario stellt sich natürlich die frage
wie gut die griechische armee eigentlich
aufgestellt ist ist sie überhaupt
irgendwie in der lage die türken von
vornherein abzuschrecken
damit sie erst gar nicht auf dumme
gedanken kommt und wie verteidigungs
bereit wäre sie im falle eines möglichen
angriffs das alles werden wir jetzt
beantworten also aufgepasst
[Musik]
das ist sparta du müsstest morgen eine
neue stelle als griechischer
verteidigungsminister antreten welche
frage würdet ihr wo die meisten
schlaflose nächte bereiten
genau wie könnte uns die türkei treffen
denn erdogan hat eine neue lieblings
doch mal was zu deutsch blaue heimat
eine doktrin wird er die türkei die
kontrolle über die gewässer der
östlichen ägäis und das wirklich im
mittelmeer ist beansprucht und die
hoheitsrechte der griechischen insel
einfach ignoriert juli vorstellen kann
existiert die auf dieser karte dar und
schnitte grenzziehung nur in erdogans
paralleluniversum sie ist international
nicht anerkannt und besitzt daher
keinerlei gültigkeit und eines klassen
wir glauben auch mit dem allerletzten da
wird doch kein niemanden davon
überzeugen können dass sie auf all das
anspruch hätte was erdogan da in seinem
imperialen träumen herbei fantasiert
okay was mich das mal kurz erklären
als diese griechischen inseln in der
östlichen ägäis wurden im rahmen des
montreux abkommens entmilitarisiert dies
war ein im jahre 1936 unterzeichnetes
internationales abkommen griechenland
behauptet jedoch es habe jetzt durchaus
gute gründe der türkei zu misstrauen
da sie ja schon vor 40 jahren und zypern
einmarschiert sind um den hauptteil der
insel dauerhaft zu besetzen womit sie ja
ihr internationales mandat verletzt
haben daher würde die griechen nichts
dazu bewegen eine ihrer inseln schutzlos
zurückzulassen und so trieben sich
dieses jahr statt der üblichen
heerscharen von touristen viele
griechische soldaten auf einer dieser
ägäischen inseln herum und natürlich
liegt der türkische protest nicht lange
auf sich warten
die türkei sagt griechenland habe
unrechtmäßig mehr truppen auf costa rico
stationierter national hurts angesichts
dieses szenarios ist offensichtlich dass
die türkische invasion drohen könnte
auf jeder insel in der östlichen ägäis
die nach den vorstellungen von ankara in
ihrer neuen blauen heimatlied und etwas
anderes scheint auch offensichtlich klar
zu sein
in einem direkten militärischen konflikt
wäre die türkei den griechen sowohl
zahlenmäßig als auch technologisch
überlegen auffälliger weise erfolgte
gerade kürzlich die stationierung der
türkischen armee in izmir und diese
verfügen nicht nur über umfangreiche
luftstreitkräfte sondern auch besonders
viele spezialisierte einheiten zur
durchführung einer landungsoperation
darüber hinaus steht kurz davor ihrem
ersten hubschrauberträger zu erhalten
der von einem türken spanischen joint
venture entwickelt und gebaut wurde
überhaupt für griechenland einen mit der
türkei vergleichbare rüstungsindustrie
und dennoch könnte eine mittelschwere
konzentration ausgewogene verlaufen als
es den anschein hat
griechenland wartet seit jahrzehnten auf
einem türkischen schachzug und hat den
vorteil dass das du verteidigende gebiet
sehr klein ist so dass die zahlenmäßige
überlegenheit der türken nicht so
wichtig wäre das schlimmste szenario für
griechenland wäre natürlich dass erdogan
sich vor vollendete tatsachen nach putin
spanier setzt die alexion der creme hat
gezeigt dass die invasion ist der rektor
i ums nur mit einer sofortigen und
energischen und mindestens
proportionalen reaktion aktiviert werden
kann
und sie hat uns auch gezeigt dass die
meisten westlichen länder zu einer
solchen reaktion ohne nicht mehr in der
lage sind eine blitz operation der
türkei zur übernahme einer insel wie
kostüme rieso die einige kilometer vor
der türkischen küste liegt und kaum 500
einwohner zählt würde erdogan einen
druckmittel in die hand geben mit dem er
seine verhandlungsposition über diese
rechte in der ägäis und im gesamten
mittelmeer in ordnung stärken könnte und
um diese situation zu vermeiden
organisiert griechenland gerade die
verteidigung sondern inseln ganz nach
der art der antiken stadt an
das erklärt zum einen liefen die türkei
angebrachten truppenbewegungen aber
diese sind nur die sichtbare spitze des
eisbergs an erster stelle geht es um die
modernisierung der griechischen armee
und die griechische regierung nutzt
dafür momentan sollte ich alle
möglichkeiten die ihr zur verfügung
stehen am deutlichsten wird dies bei
modernsten kampfflugzeug der welt der
s35 schon ist das mal etwas genauer
türkei ist den kalten krieg eigentlich
ein enger verbündeter der vereinigten
staaten daher von es weder die nato noch
das weiße haus auch noch ein bisschen
toll dass erdogan zu seiner armee das
russische luft ab das system es ist die
100 gekauft habt so in brüssel als auch
in washington als auch im pentagon in
arlington wären sie ziemlich blöd wählen
sie eines ihrer besten kampfflugzeuge an
jemanden aushändigen würden der haut mit
der gegenseite zusammenarbeitet die
genau jede raketen entwickelt mit denen
dieses kampflugzeug abgeschossen werden
soll
nein in washington war damit klar wo
ihre schmuckstücke besser aufgehoben
sind
griechenland wird 6 f 35 6 in dienst
stellen die ursprünglich für die türkei
gedacht waren
the herald und nicht nur das erdogan
haben mit diesem affront nicht nur
washington und akten nähergebracht nein
er wurde damit quasi ungewollt zu
griechenlands chefdiplomaten eigentlich
müsste aus athen ein extra gehalt
bekommt denn das wasser verbracht haben
bisher noch nicht mal die halle hat
besten top-diplomaten griechenlands
hingekriegt einen festen verteidigungs
block der ganzen region gegen die türkei
zudem länder wie ägypten und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate zählen
sogar ägypten griechenland ein abkommen
zur maritimen demarkation geschlossen
auch den emiraten kommt dieses bündnis
nur recht da sie den beziehungen der
türkei zu ihren rivalen sowieso
misstrauisch gegenüberstehen als zeichen
der verbundenheit und als signal gegen
ankara schon auf israel und zypern
gemeinsame militärmanöver mit
griechenland die einst ausgezeichneten
beziehungen zwischen israel und der
türkei sind durch ein tor des
nationalstürmers muss auf einem neuen
tiefpunkt und das nicht nur weil sich
die beiden und das gas unter dem
meeresboden des mittelmeers streit
hinzu kommen frankreich und italien zwei
sehr einflussreiche länder welche die
europäische union ist nicht das
mitbringen werden erdogan in seine
schranken zu weisen
frankreichs präsident marco geht es
dabei nicht nur darum dass erdogan
persönlich beleidigt hat und den inneren
frieden in frankreich durch religiöse
hätte stirn will
nein auch hier geht es um knallharte
geschäftsinteressen griechenlands kauf
von in frankreich hergestellten
kampfflugzeugen im wert von zwei
milliarden euro
freak city times
ja genau griechenland kauft für 1,7
milliarden euro 18
rafale-kampfjets und für weitere 300
millionen euro auch noch ein paar andere
waffen wie du siehst richtig
griechenland vor allem seine luftwaffe
auf dennis weiß die türkische luftwaffe
ist die achillesferse erdogan ohne
lufthoheit wäre eine invasion nur schwer
möglich
trotz ihrer viel größeren armee haben
die türken also militärisch keinen haus
holen vorteil der ihnen ein schnell sie
garantieren würde
vielleicht sollten sie jedoch versuchen
mehr bündnispartner zu gewinnen wie
wär's zum beispiel mit deutschland
deutschland ist zwar kein mittelmeerland
wenn man mal vom inoffiziellen sitzen
bundesland mallorca ab sieht aber es hat
in der eu doch gehörig mitzureden und in
deutschland legen fast vier millionen
menschen türkischer herkunft
der anteil überzeugter erdogan anhänger
unter ihnen ist überwältigend groß
dieser ist viel größer als in der türkei
selbst das zu schweigen von den modernen
regionen im westen istanbul ganz mama
aber auch anker und viele millionen in
deutschland lebende dollar verfügen die
in ihrer türkischen auch über einen
deutschen pass womit sie das privileg
haben sowohl in deutschland als auch der
türkei das wahlrecht zu genießen
sie haben damit sozusagen ein doppelt so
großes politisches gewicht als menschen
mit nur einem passt sie können also
sowohl die politik der türkei als auch
die deutschlands maßgeblich bestimmen
denn politiker beider länder müssen um
ihre stimmen buhlen erdogan tue dies
natürlich ausgiebig und auch deutsche
politiker stehen unter großem druck ist
berlin also aus diesem grund nachsichtig
mit erdogan und übt es deswegen druck
auf athen aus nun zumindest versucht
griechenlands zeit doch ein wenig das
wohlwollen leute politiker zurück zu
bekommen
durch die bestellung von vier fregatten
für seine marine millionen euro gegen
millionen wähler zwei in der politik
durch auswechselbare währung aber moment
mal war griechenland vor ein paar jahren
irgendwie pleite haben die eurozone und
vor allem deutschland ihn nicht mit dem
milliardentransfers aus der patsche
geholfen und im gegenzug massiven
einfluss auf die griechische politik
genommen haben sich die dinge in athen
um so sehr verändert dass sie ohne namen
von geld für rüstungsausgaben übrig
haben irgendwas passt doch nicht
zusammen oder gut dann gehen wir den
ball auf den grund sieht nach einem
ziemlich entscheidenden puzzlestück aus
nicht wahr
von der drachen drama
[Musik]
seit technolit auf wirtschaftlicher
ebene gründungsmitglied der eurozone
wurde hat ist nichts als ärger
verursacht von denen maßlos überteuerten
olympischen spielen über dreisten
systematisches subventionsbetrug
unvorstellbaren ausmaßes bis zu einem
staatswesen das und einer kollektiven
schmerzhaften versorgungsmentalität in
geiselhaft genommen wurde
griechenland so wirtschaftete seitdem
weit über seine verhältnisse und
eigentlich was ständig am rande der
krise jahrelang wurden begriffe wie die
troika rettungsschirm stärker mit diesem
land passiert als urlaubsfreuden und
griechischer joghurt aber die situation
hat sich seither erheblich besser für
seine staatsanleihen mit einer laufzeit
von zehn jahren muss griechenland nur
noch eine rendite von 0,68 prozent
bieten während diese 2012 bei fast 40
prozent lag im klartext athen kann nun
wieder ohne allzu grosse schwierigkeiten
haufenweise neue schulden aufnehmen und
dafür waffen kaufen wo also liegt das
problem nun die krone krise hat auch in
griechenland formel hinterlassen da
wären lockt das und natürlich der
einbruch der tourismuseinnahmen alice
hat einen noch größeren appetit
griechenlands auf null schulden und
damit das misstrauen der investoren
ausgelöst
griechenlands staatsverschuldung im jahr
2020 bei 200 8,9 prozent seines
bruttoinlandsprodukts yahoo finance im
november stand griechenland vor einem
zweiten landesweiten lockdown die
griechische wirtschaft wird in diesem
jahr um mehr als zehn prozent einbrechen
wie du dir vorstellen kannst scheint
dies nicht gerade die allerbeste zeit
für einen kriegsabenteuer zu sein bei
dem athen im grunde nichts zu gewinnen
hat aber viel verlieren kann
die militärausgaben griechenland sind es
hat dem jahr 2013 um zehn prozent
gestiegen aber das türkische militär
budget ist immer noch dreimal so hoch
ich bin also ziemlich sicher dass
niemand in der teen will dass eines
ihrer neuen rolle und kampfflugzeuge
stückkosten über 100 millionen euro über
der ägäis abgeschossen wird ja wenn du
jetzt aber dachte dass athen schon knapp
bei kasse
schau doch mal wie es auf der anderen
seite des bosporus aussieht vor einem
dreiviertel jahr haben sie in einem
video schon mal erklärt warum die türkei
andere andere der pleite stand schon
damals die nicht wieso die türkische
lira ist diese in der zwischenzeit
nochmals um 50 prozent eingebrochen
damals also nicht auf uns gehört und
seine türkischen staatsanleihen behalten
hat müsste die hälfte seine investition
eine und investoren zogen bereits viele
milliarden aus afrika erdogan vernichtet
jedoch nicht nur das geld von anlegern
sondern auch das
die eigenen landsleute um steuerzahler
diebinnen inflation schoss gerade auf 14
prozent hoch und für ihre staatsanleihen
muss die türkei den anlegern über 13
prozent rendite bieten damit er
überhaupt jemand neues geld leiht das
ist 26 mal mehr als im falle
griechenlands
[Musik]
aber zurück eg ist wenn wir alle diese
dinge die wir hier aufgezählt haben
zusammenfassen
doch irgendwie auch dass es momentan
einfach sehr schwierig zu sein scheint
zu sagen welche der beiden streithähne
türkei oder griechenland sich in einem
solchen kräftemessen er ruiniert würde
wenn also früher die puste ausgeht weil
wirtschaft und währung zusammenbrechen
und wahrscheinlich sind auch weder athen
noch am kahlen gerade dieses risiko
abzuschätzen
beide haben also ganz realistisch
gesehen durchaus ein interesse sich
friedlich zu einigen zumindest wenn man
davon ausgeht dass ich hinter all dem
macho-gehabe doch rationalen spieler
befinden traditionell war die nato jene
arena auf der griechenland die türkei
ihre historischen differenzen auf
diplomatischem weg vorläufig beigelegt
haben und was es in einem bündnis das
aus den kalten krieg hervorgehen die
klassische lösung kunst richtig zu
entschärfen bingo eine telefonleitung
laut nato haben griechenland und die
türkei eine hotline eingerichtet um
zusammenstöße im östlichen
mittelmeerraum zu vermeiden
ja so sind wir dies auch gelingt dieser
hotline könnte eine art joker zu einer
win win situation seien in der jeder
genau das bekommt worum es ihnen
eigentlich geht sowohl erdogan als auch
die griechischen nationalisten kurz mit
medialen drohungen und die säbel rasseln
ihre anhänger bei laune halten ohne dass
es wirklich zu einem militärischen
konflikt kommt denn sobald alle verbalen
eskalationsstufen erreicht sind nutzen
sie sich einfach auf der heimleitung an
das tool ihren sich gegenseitig zudem so
gemeinschaftlich erreichten hohen
popularitätswerten bei der
chauvinistische wählerschaft und können
in aller ruhe ausmachen die sie auch die
nächste runde beide seiten
gesichtswahrend im sande verlaufen
lassen können und vielleicht auch mit
welcher strategie sie in die nächste
runde dieser schönen funktionierenden
wähler apple umgehen können damit es
nicht wirklich zu missverständnissen
kommt so und parallel dazu können die
verhandlungen über die hoheitsgewässer
und das recht die ressourcen unter dem
meeresboden auszubeuten auf
diplomatischem weg weitergehen wenn sich
die griechische linie durchsetzt wurde
die türkei leer ausgehen obwohl ihr
vorkommen will er zu ihrer küste liegen
aber auch die position der türkei ist
gar nicht mal so schlecht an einer
dauerhaften art situation durch welche
die schätze unter dem meeresboden
bleiben und leer ist keine der beiden
seiten wirklich interessiert daher ist
es sehr wahrscheinlich dass sich über
kurz oder lang beide parteien ein
internationales schiedsgericht wenden
werden und dieses entscheidet dann nach
gerechtigkeit und billigkeit denn die
abgrenzung von festland sachen und
wirtschaftsräumen orientiert sich nicht
zwingend an der mittellinie zu festen
in der internationalen streit beilegen
zu grenzstreitigkeiten ist anerkannt
dass die länge der küstenlinie eine
rolle spielt und berücksichtigt wird und
dass kleinere inseln die eine
grenzziehung zu stark verzerren würden
entspricht weniger ins gewicht fällt das
seerechtsübereinkommen als auch das
gewohnheitsrecht lassen durchaus eine
gemeinsame ausbeutung der
rohstoffvorkommen ohne und aus
festlegung des grenzverlaufs zu mit
einer solchen lösung könnten so gut
wirtschaftliche interessen als auch
politische gesichtswahrung auf allen
seiten befriedigt werden aber wie auch
in visual politik werden diese spannende
entwicklungen auge und dich auf dem
laufenden halten
so und jetzt wo wir die einen
umfassenden überblick geliefert haben
bist du an der reihe
glaubst du dass wir zu optimistisch sind
was die chancen einer diplomatischen
lösung angeht könnte irgendwas
vielleicht innenpolitischen
entwicklungen einen der akteure dazu
bringen die situation ins extreme zu
eskalieren
glaubst du dass griechenland aus
diplomatischen und militärischen ebene
die richtigen schritte unternimmt um
sich eine türkische offensive wieder
setzen zu können und was vielleicht
besser für uns oder gegen uns alles was
ihr das so einfällt in die kommentare
denn wie immer sind wir auf diese schon
hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe dass
dieses video gefallen uns vielleicht
etwas gebracht hat das jahr geht uns
bitte einen daumen hoch und unterstütze
uns indem du es mit deinen freunden
und vergesst bitte nicht dass wir jede
woche neue videos hochladen abonnieren
sie unseren kanal und klick auf das
symbol und rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu
merken machs gut und bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]